[Music]
and beer saves lives news that's the
first submitted by fart right now Bart
oh you can on command no I tried to try
to push a bottle at me there was a fart
smell like sin regret child kidnapping
slave doesn't smell bad but his fart is
like pure evil
it can start World War three dude I'm
actually so happy I have instilled in me
to to have a child in a minute I've
trained that release from just out of
curiosity you don't want to experience
it you don't guys are hyping it up a lot
if you get upset or disgusted we're
cutting you out of our lab lemme just be
impressed
let's go get some Mexican food it's
worse than the porta potty let's go get
Indian food I'm down I'll go I'll feed
you the exact paneer is it takbir yeah
yeah that's the spinach and cheese thing
that was tofu you know that's cheese bro
you can't make it with tofu for lactose
really any food today yeah one of my
buddy's restaurants in downtown LA you
guys should go it's called the mosh it's
like that is the [ __ ] I live like what
time 8 miles away from there that place
is good that's like a firm day I'm gonna
talk to them but oh wait I think that
means he like invited us and he's like
[ __ ] the accepted I [ __ ] you want to
hear the funniest [ __ ] about that
[ __ ] rice no I'll cancel all just
come to your host if it's your friends
then only these [ __ ] just chill
outside then you're smoking it drink it
just time how'd you like the food I was
like what the [ __ ] but every time I
walked by that place it smells so good
and then right after I get hit with bump
his smell oh wow but that area just
right there I'm like oh small so [ __ ]
good and it's like [ __ ] there's [ __ ]
bum vomit [ __ ]
a [ __ ] dog dukey and then it's uh and
I gotta go walk backwards is mango lassi
American as an Indian eight miles away
like the fortune cookies I can watch a
cookie or a California roll second
American beer delivery men talked a
suicidal man off a highway ledge with an
offer to share a drink that's dope dude
that's just like your your empathy it's
like let me talk to you I'll be
listening it's like that's what they
need that's all they need huh someone to
talk to that I bet you that person
wasn't an Asian person though because
they were just yelled at him yeah hurry
up go kill yourself already go do it
lose it yeah you [ __ ] I bet you won't
do it he does it oh [ __ ] no the Asian
cops don't have negotiators they just
have a sniper that helps you do it
faster yo I saw this one it's [ __ ]
wild in China they have like these
secret agent cops that are like just
riding bicycles and then like if there's
a hostage situation they look like the
public and they'll just jump off and
[ __ ] and blast the the person in the
face or like they'll climb up parkour
style then they'll like [ __ ] shoot
them in the head like that it's crazy
and then sometimes they're like four
feet old ladies I'm exaggerating but
there are male female and then they look
like just normal people I dunno ladies
no but they literally look like
someone's made like they just finish
scrubbing someone's feet yeah I also
believe that Asia East Asians are the
genetically the most superior Havens
what are you seeing such that was one of
the funniest things I've ever heard yeah
I've never heard that give you I call
this so no I think I think Asians East
Asians are I don't know because I think
you have water seen such honest things
I'm listening athletically you're more
superior depends on the specimen because
because it's not just your don't just
focus on athletics like there's a whole
meditational spiritual element behind it
there's so many different elements it's
a good balance of everything so I think
you guys you know a lot of stuff came
from India right like karate martial
arts all that stuff so I'm saying I
think India was like that once too but
then we got a call
now we're all just lazy or not on time
and just hate each other
I have never met a lazy Indian no no no
sorry they're not lazy but we're thought
have you seen engineering departments in
America well I'm just roasting my own
people you know what you're educated
you're Canadian Indian so like our
stereotype of Indians you don't see ones
the last time you saw Indian hath Leon a
major Indian honest on a sports no
there's a there's an American food
because we don't find it we don't
support like we we support India's you
just sound like a regular Asian now well
we really support like a I team that's
like India's biggest export is iTunes
the thing is in Southern California the
stereotype we have about Indians is
they're all upper-middle class and then
they all have high paid jobs and stuff
but like I know in the East Coast are
like in Canada there's a lot of like
lower-class
Indians right all of kit all the
Canadian immigrants are like lower class
right like all labor work yeah that's a
stereotype we have in California is all
Indians and American Indians are a
completely different and Canadian yeah
like we're we all look at America needs
to be like those bastards they're all
rich like I come to American Indian
people thousand like you guys house is
this big like doesn't you guys live cuz
we grew up in like poor [ __ ] I grew up
poor [ __ ] all my friends that are Indian
we all grew up poor like and like word
the guys are making money now cuz we're
actually like you know figuring it out
but like when we went to like a boy I
went to my Indian relatives house in
America like I'm like man you guys are
so rich you guys have you guys have an
n64 and a Playstation [ __ ]
yep both like people have both consoles
I was like while you guys are rich like
it's like we only got to pick one and
still we were still a generation behind
like the PlayStation 2 was out and I was
still playing PlayStation did you look
like snobby ass Indian people to like
where they would just like talk down to
like people with like certain last names
because I had like this girl in my high
school I thought our last name was sing
and she was like how [ __ ] dare you
I was like oh I don't know what that bet
other caste system was like so talk to
us oh sheesh I got Patel or something
she was a Patel oh she was a Patel yeah
and then she was like she was like no
I'm not a singer I was like that's like
that's like that's like going to a
Korean person be like oh your tie
because India is so diverse like a drop
is Patel and Singh is probably Punjabi
and those are like completely different
and India's like a miniature Africa
because it's like every 200 kilometers
or 100 kilometers a Yugo is a complete
different language food everything
yeah how many miles whatever 500 miles
sure we're the only idiots that still
use that [ __ ] so this takes place in
Minnesota it's shameful and this dude
you speak like Canadians why did the
chicken cross the road
yes how rude so these two men they're
making delivery because they work for
the beverage company and a delivery man
named Jason and Kwame and they were both
what were they delivering Hanson's
Hanson's right no like they had beer so
that was what made the headline I think
there it was in the title duh so they
were drinking and driving basically you
know what you're saying no their
delivers okay you're deliver yeah
beverage delivers but they had beer in
the truck so anyway so they see this
dude he's standing on the other side of
the overpass it took a picture of him
like the other that is scary dude
they're saying that this is like divine
intervention because they usually take
another route but for some reason they
don't give a [ __ ]
drinking and driving through their
emotional right now
yes man he was by the job delivery guy
he's smiling ya know yes cuz he had a
[ __ ] in his like dad was a good beer
then why go to the back of the job it's
just such a it's such an extreme thing
that happened but now he's like smiling
in this picture like everything's good
again that's probably really good beers
I'm really dark time and if I saw a guy
on the freeway like that I would just
think he's a tagger
oh no but if you see somebody like
trying to climb the fence and on the
ledge on my way to church when I was a
kid there was a dude that you know how
the fence curves like this that guys
somehow grabbed jumped on top and he was
on the thing about to jump over the
freeway pass cuz there's a freeway pass
before you get to my church
it was just bawling his eyes out just
screaming and crying cops are trying to
get him down
and that happened a lot at that one
particular spot I have no [ __ ] idea
why but a lot of people try to kill
themselves over there and so that's why
they occurred there but that guy got
above the curb curve part of the fence
and was trying to kill himself I just
get angry that they [ __ ] caused
traffic so you just proved my Asian
Finnerty out right now you don't even
know I'm heartless thanks a lot [ __ ]
like it's selfish it's very selfish
because not only df/de that's not their
fault man they're like you gotta be
empathetic at the same time it's like
you're going to [ __ ] I go through some
[ __ ] all the time you are a strong
powerful man no no what I'm saying if is
I go through [ __ ] all the time if I
decide to walk into the street and start
shooting people that's different
but that's different why is that
different than killing yourself yeah
because you're taking other people's
lives well in this case I'm saying like
he could if he did job it could hurt
other people too but if that's not his
intention if you're like my James I'm
gonna go [ __ ] everybody up there I shoot
myself that's most cowardice thing you
do yeah but like someone who's like I
want to kill themselves it's like well
you're just nobody has something they
don't have anybody to talk to it's like
that like this that's I mean that's
that's okay I guess it's the way that
it's done I think what Joe is trying to
say if you're gonna jump don't jump
during rush hour by jump at 2:00 a.m.
when the freeways are clear thank you
fine fine that's what I'm trying to say
be considerate of the jump I'm a little
bit selfish clips because they want to
be talked down they want someone to talk
to they don't want to really low key you
do awesome okay so there it's a cry for
help it's like it's like it's like it's
like when you're at the club and then
you're hoping that like while you're
about to get into fight a security comes
and holds you back when you really don't
want to fight but you want to look okay
I get it but then see I'm not I'm not
trying to knock on suicide and people
being depressed and stuff like that I'm
just saying like it's it's just very
very selfish to do that like to want
attention so badly that you're willing
to [ __ ] up so many people's dates but at
the same time you're having a logical
argument with someone that's
the complete opposite right there
they're about to and they're like
they're they're an inconvenience to the
world it'll be better off without them
like they're thinking me oh so there's
two different conversations out but what
about the other so I'm talking about in
the spectrum of suicide right there are
people who'll do the pill thing there
are people who will blast themselves
there people that will do many many
different methods of suicide people just
want to have a little bit of fun before
they go you know it's like we met one
last like pill you're just kind of like
fall asleep and then it blood when you
PI you're sorry like got a balloon out
in your pain
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]